[Musique]
depuis toujours on nous dit que nos vies
doivent être orchestrée au quart de tour
que chaque minute compte
cuisine express recettes rapides riz
minutes il faut gagner du temps coûte
que coûte
on a de la difficulté à retrouver son
souffle on arrive le soir les gens ont
faim les enfants ont faim dalphond
lorsqu'on un signal très simple de dire
28,60 able to peace est réglé c'est
beaucoup pour beaucoup de consommateurs
beaucoup de consommatrices l'industrie
en profite et nous offre une multitude
d'aliments prêts l'avait prépensionnés
précuits même du poulet ray coupé comme
à laval et pas n'importe quoi manger le
nouveau poulet précoupés d'exceldor en
faire un come filet médaillon et la new
york
on nous promet plus de temps mais qu'en
est il vraiment l'épicerie a voulu
savoir combien de temps on gagne et
combien ça nous coûte nous avons donc
préparé des repas d'une journée pour une
personne d'abord un bon petit déjeuner
maison avec pamplemousse grue yo yo
gourd aux noix et café et son équivalent
proportionnée pour un pamplemousse en
petit pot de plastique on gagne 2
minutes 12 secondes en temps puisqu'on
n'a pas à le couper les bûchers et le
portionné acheter entier et nous en
coûtera 66,5 pour 90 g de chair versus
de dollars 10,9 pour la même quantité en
petits pots
nous avons calculé un gros 56 secondes
pour préparer notre propre yo gourd
l'ensemble yugo rhinois ne coûtera 1
dans leurs 90 la portion de 150 grammes
la version maison 76 cents de moins soit
1 dollar 14 le test du sachet de gruau
même quantité d'eau même temps de
cuisson même casse-tête gruau différence
et celle ci alors on fait le tiers de
tasses ou encore que ceux ci le tir de
danse même durée autre exemple le café
69,5 en dosettes ou la même quantité
dans un filtre réutilisables pour
seulement 34 seul on gagne quarante et
une secondes mais on le paie deux fois
plus cher
tellement que ça prend beaucoup plus de
temps c'est que ça nous permet de penser
qu'on va mettre ce temps là à autre
chose c'est surtout d'enfants de dire te
pas le goût de le faire fait les cool
ici on a des selleries sont déjà dans
une barquette 8 dollars 80
c'est un dollar avouez que couper le
céleri la ville portionné le mettre dans
une petite barquette contact après ça
c'est clair
on parle d'un profil moyen brut sur des
produits de base à murray 19/20 pour ça
là on est rendu dans le sang pour ça ces
danses à 150% facilement mais dans le
fond le signal qu'on vous donne c'est
voici une partie qui est pas plaisant
pour vous dans votre journée consacrée
dont votre temps à faire quelque chose
de mieux
nous on va s'occuper de la partie non
plaisante ce qu'on vous dit pas
évidemment sais combien vous vous
chargez pour s'occuper de la partie qui
ne vous plait plus notre repas du midi
comprenait entre autres une salade
grecque
accompagné de deux heures un gain de
temps de 19 minutes mais la salade vendu
5 dollars 29 a coûté 4 $ de plus que si
on l'avait fait nous mêmes face d eux d
eux des jacqueries des cultures
vous n aurez pas besoin de faire cuire
mais en plus j'ai pas besoin d'aidé et
cahiers parce que le grand risque des
gens encore une fois là dedans c'est
peut-être qu'il va être occupée c'est
cuit déjà comparé d'ouvrir un oeuf qui
serait pas ce qu'il est c'est fou ce que
je veux dire mais le risque d'erreur est
important mais n'a pour les
consommateurs et des consommateurs le
plus tendance à mesurer
c'est comme ma grand mère se servait de
toit mais j'en ai même pas la maison
deux exemples qui étonne un emballage de
pommes de terre devant du avec un season
man ou encore ces galettes de viande
hachée au poivre qui prennent moins
d'une minute à faire
élève de boeuf assaisonné au point
galette de boeuf assaisonné au poivre
que l'on parte le chronomètre s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
top chrono revenons à notre test c'est
super fête à la maison qui a nécessité
le plus tant préparation soit 1h18
mais si on retranche le temps de cuisson
des betteraves qui est quand même
considérable le temps total de
préparation et de huit minutes 21
secondes
de plus on ne perd du coup notre
relation avec les aliments avec la
préparation d'aliments
on dirait qu'on fait beaucoup de
recettes qu'on va recevoir des gens mais
pour tous les jours on veut éviter tout
seul et on achète tout fait
et ce tous fait produit une quantité
considérable d'emballage marc la noche
seul un spécialiste en environnement
le demain le plus c'est vraiment
l'emballage supplémentaire qui est
requis aux aliments pour pouvoir avoir
une durée de vie plus longue des leçons
prend l'exemple d'un pamplemousse qui a
déjà sa protection naturelle une fois
qu'ils aient coupé mais on a besoin de
mettre une nouvelle protection et on a
besoin en plus de les réfrigérer pour
qu'on garde sa durée de vie
contrairement à un pamplemousse qui peut
rester serein sur la tablette pc corps
et donc c'est vraiment un impact plus
large sur que l'on voit beaucoup
l'emballage mais l'impact qui va plus
loin que ça aussi dans la préparation du
vote dans la réfrigération et vol dans
l'espace supplémentaire qu'ils
l'espèrent supplémentaire des tablettes
réfrigérée en supermarché l'espace
supplémentaire dans nos frigos chez nous
donc tout ça a aussi un impact qu'on
voit moins faudra repenser dans les 3 r
le premier c'est réduction donc réussir
à réduire les quantités d'emballages
qu'on fait implique aussi de faire un
peu plus la nourriture même coupé
nauheim en maille pas selon don exemple
on constate que pour trois repas une
personne seule gamme 23 minutes dans sa
journée en utilisant du prix portionné
mais hélas 15 $ de moins dans ses poches
c'est un manque de 105 dollars par
semaine et de 420 dollars par mois
imaginez le coût pour une année
[Musique]